peaker's Advantage is the bane of every
FPS player's existence
my golly go LLY gosh
[Music]
under okay wait oh my God
this guy's cheating regardless of the
game peaker's Advantage is widely
considered to be one of the most
significant issues tactical FPS
developers face
oh my gosh
it looks like a full model almost and
even if its existence is inevitable you
can't deny that being on the receiving
end of it
is very frustrating when every
millisecond and input makes a difference
in these games knowing that your enemy
can simply see you before you see them
just feels unfair playing on high ping
is obviously really annoying I mean it's
the same with like CS go but you have
incredible Pickers Advantage but at the
same time holding angles is
very very difficult on high ping and for
essentially a decade this felt like an
unfixable aspect of shooters that we all
just had to accept that was until one
company decided to do something about it
when Riot games first announced valorent
they made a promise to all but eliminate
peaker's Advantage we all thought it was
impossible and it turns out two years
after the game's release
we were right
what happened what just happened
he was just standing there one more hit
for 78.
what but to Riot's credit they did
earnestly try to make improvements and
the truth is that even though peaker's
Advantage sucks
it might also be kind of a good thing
[Applause]
hey folks before we get into my second
favorite pastime which is [__] on
Riot I would like to remind you all that
we have merch head over to
shop.thescore.com to buy T-shirts and
hoodies and I can personally guarantee
that for every piece of our merch that
you wear at the same time you will shave
10 milliseconds off of your network
latency
can I guarantee that like legally all
right so before we get into all of this
I should probably explain what peaker's
advantage actually is since it can get
kind of complicated so let me explain it
in gamer friendly terms let's say you're
holding an angle in an online match
walk straight into your Crosshair as any
good Defender would but before your
brain can even react your opponent flies
around the corner and running one Taps
you after that you're probably thinking
one of three things they're hacking the
dude has Godlike pre-fire angles or he
had R and Jesus on his side but more
often than not what actually occurred
peaker's advantage basically in nearly
every single online shooter you play an
opponent who Peaks will be able to see
you for a few frames before you see them
now the question is why does peaker's
Advantage exist in the first place
well that's the million dollar question
I said that's the million dollar quick
Colton buddy that's your cue come on and
now the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about whoa hold on Dimitri I
don't get paid millions of dollars to
answer these questions either I do this
at a pure philanthropy and the kindness
of my science loving heart anyway
peeker's Advantage is caused by a
multitude of factors like Ping your
isp's infrastructure tick rate and the
actual server itself any combination of
these can dictate the severity of said
picker's advantage
city correct
Yeah
[Music]
we actually already did a pretty
comprehensive breakdown on all of these
things and are cracked on PING so make
sure to check that out for the sake of
this video I'll try not to complicate
things too much because there's really
only one major thing you need to know
information does not travel
instantaneously when you play a game
online your inputs go through quite the
process which takes a certain amount of
time before the information reaches the
server and ultimately the rest of the
players in the game that time in between
is where the peakers advantage generally
lives so to break it all down let's take
a look at Dimitri's peaking example and
use valorent since Riot has been kind
enough to tell us how some of their neck
code actually works since it may take
different amounts of time for
information to travel to and from the
server for two different players Riot
servers introduce a small buffer that
ensures that within the margin of that
buffer both players inputs are applied
to the game state at the correct time
but if you have an unreasonably High
ping well there's only so much Riot can
do about you getting that information
significantly later than an opponent
with an excellent ping and if your
opponent has ping noticeably longer than
the buffer time all the less time you'll
have to react to them rounding a corner
while the fine folks at valve and other
major devs have been given us quite as
much insight into their net code there
are undoubtedly some similar measures in
place to help mitigate ping variants and
in the same way these measures can help
minimize peaker's advantage
to a point and that was the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
now the fact of the matter is that
peaker's Advantage has just always sort
of existed and for us CS diehards it's
something that we've kind of just come
to terms with that being said having
poor Network infrastructure and only 64
tick servers for competitive play
doesn't make the pill any easier to
swallow but that's what brings us to
valorent the Revolutionary FPS title
that was going to fix all of that and
offer so much more you see leading up to
its launch Riot promised that valorent
would deliver three things precise gun
play
what the [__] is that abilities that
provide a tactical advantage
and a system that went to war on
peaker's Advantage yeah I got him I got
him three two
[Music]
one
I died before he peeked
oh what Spike planted so yeah these
things didn't happen and valerik was and
still is memed into Oblivion for it but
omitting spray patterns and um adding
chamber these were likely philosophical
decisions made by Riot and not mistakes
but what about the war on peaker's
Advantage limiting it as much as
possible is a net positive for any game
so what happened exactly well Valor
launched with 128 tick servers and what
appears to be a better Network meaning
you get information faster than you
would in CS matchmaking but even then it
still somehow sometimes feels worse and
I I don't think I'm the only one who
feels this way back in March of 2021 100
thieves were fined for delaying their
online match against Immortals hundred
thieves delayed their match because they
felt that the server they were about to
play on would give Immortals an unfair
paying Advantage right and they have a
guy at eight pain
yeah what about the AP versus 40. no
they're not that's the same one has a
crazy peakers advantage and the other
one has it working against him man
there is a huge difference with 18
compared to 44 by the way now it's not
like CS go has never had an issue like
this before I mean due to covet or VISA
issues we have seen some insane ping in
a handful of professional matches
ultimately it's possible that the reason
that valorin's peaker's Advantage feels
so much worse
just because of the way the game is
designed for starters getting headshots
in valorent is a lot easier than in CS
go sometimes peeking around a corner and
one tapping someone with the Vandal is
Child's Play and I'm watching highlights
nowadays on Twitter it's just like the
people are actually like proud of the
highlights they're doing but when I see
the way like they shoot and the way they
get the Highlights I'm like it looks
easy it's not so hard to do this you
know then there's movement in CS go it's
fast and floaty letting you counter
strafe and jiggle to help combat
peaker's Advantage but valorence
movement feels let's say inconsistent on
one hand beginning to move feels like
you're starting up a lawnmower but as
shroud pointed out
stopping is quite the opposite you stop
on a dime in this game so like when
you're
you start shooting when you see the
person and your character just stops
because they stop so fast and it looks
like you're running and head shotting
but you're actually not running in
headshotting it's just that you stop so
quick in this game so on top of counter
strafing not being as effective and the
fact that it's more difficult to lead
your opponent peaker's Advantage can
feel a lot harder to combat mix that
with how easy it is to headshot and well
you get the valorent experience
foreign
but if it's not Ryan's fault then how do
you get rid of it well unless you're
playing on land where there's virtually
no latency
it's impossible so unfortunately a lot
of the onus plans on us you see just as
much as your enemy's ping can affect
their peaker's advantage your own
latency can affect your quote unquote
holders disadvantage some would even say
that's the only thing that matters if
you're running on a Wi-Fi card and a 60
hertz monitor while downloading all six
seasons of The Sopranos
you're just gonna have to accept that
that's the hand you've been built back
in 2020 Nvidia even released a case
study with nothing discussing how low
latency systems can actually help
eliminate peaker's Advantage often
Gamers attribute ticker's Advantage only
to Game net code or network latency
however let's look at the role of system
latency and Peter's advantage in this
first test we're going to be looking at
our low latency system peeking into our
medium latency system so when we
actually peek through like a wide swing
you could just see the major difference
wow yeah yeah the wide swing you like
almost see his whole body when he sees
like your shoulder next up we have our
medium latency system peeking into our
low latency system
look at that yep crosshairs are both
almost neutralized peaker's advantage
like that's at least
even if not
favoring the lower latency system
now this is obviously easier said than
done not everyone is going to have the
money or ability to build a low latency
setup on top of that you can't control
the system someone else has and figuring
out exactly what caused the problem for
you specifically and solving it can be
impossible but maybe it's only a problem
if you choose to see it that way a liege
despite being a CS GoPro says that
peaker's advantage in valorant is a good
thing you know how hard it would be to
like play again
people are asking for something that
they're they don't even like understand
like what they're asking for well you
would have to like use utilities so much
to get anyone off of any angle
it's just not even possible to play like
that and I think there's some validity
to this coin
the lesser of two evils in the grand
scheme of things in theory holding an
angle should be easier than pushing into
one that being said reducing it as much
as possible will objectively make the
game more fair and to this day Riot are
still trying to make improvements that
fight against the issue other than
putting a server in every freaking city
in the world what should Riot do well
it's probably cheaper for them to build
a time machine go back and never make
these promises in the first place
party
you've got to come back with me now I
know this isn't the clean and tidy
conclusion we all wanted to come to but
there just isn't one see there's
actually no definitive way for us to
even test what game has the worst
speaker's Advantage because I don't have
the tech valorant has no demo files and
there can always be desync issues even
if we pulled it off that would just be
our experience and peaker's Advantage
affects everyone in different ways but
that doesn't mean you can't do anything
about it streamer Royal G posted a great
Twitter Thread about experimenting with
how you Peak and hold angles valorent
and CS are games with nearly Limitless
possibilities and thinking outside the
box holding unique angles or inventing
the Honda CRV Peak can give you an edge
and maybe just maybe
it might be kind of fun
a million dollars
what do you mean I don't get a million
what do you mean it's just a turn of
phrase
I don't know if that'll that'll pan out
to be funny or not
my I mean I Envision you cutting me off
in the middle of turn